economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela
bienvenida proponen un millonario
acuerdo para zanjar la crisis de
opioides en eeuu que tal raúl primero
recordemos que son los opioides son
medicamentos hechos a base de opio que
en su momento parecieron ser la
respuesta a siglos de dolor
sin embargo tanto farmacéuticas como
distribuidores han sido acusados de
minimizar el riesgo de adicción cuando
comercializaban estos fármacos lo que a
su vez ocasionó cientos de miles de
muertes por sobredosis en este país
desde finales de la década del 90 un
grupo de fiscales generales estatales
dio a conocer un acuerdo preliminar al
que llegaron con cuatro grandes empresas
para que paguen 26.000 millones de
dólares todo para zanjar esta crisis
propio no de promueven ya que todos
sabemos que durante más de dos décadas
la epidemia de opioides ha causado
estragos en neoyorquinos y
estadounidenses en todo el país y
cientos de miles han muerto en números y
para ser claros las numerosas empresas
que fabricaron y distribuyeron este
veneno lo hicieron
consideración por la vida humana y por
la crisis nacional que causaron todos
los involucrados raúl son la
farmacéutica johnson y johnson y los
tres distribuidores más grandes de eeuu
mckesson corp cardinal jefe y
amerisourcebergen corp
el dinero será utilizado como una forma
de reparar a los afectados por ejemplo
tratamiento de adicciones apoyo familiar
educación y otros programas sociales
ahora los estados tienen 30 días para
evaluar el acuerdo que sería el segundo
de este tipo más grande de la historia y
cambiamos ahora desde manila porque por
fin celebró un acuerdo para construir un
polémico gasoducto en europa se trata
del gasoducto nord stream 2 que ya está
casi listo y que unirá a rusia con
alemania por el mar báltico para
llevarles combustible pero eeuu siempre
se ha opuesto rotundamente porque cree
que el kremlin podría utilizar la
energía como una arma política para
extender su influencia en europa sin
embargo washington acordó con berlín que
se complete el proyecto a cambio de que
alemania se comprometa a que apoyara
sanciones contra rusia
si es que esto llegara a suceder y
también que garantice el suministro
energético de ucrania que sabemos es un
gran aliado de la casa blanca en la
región y terminó prosigan dolores de
cabeza porque un nuevo capítulo de
atención sobre el proxy daniela claro
raúl pues el protocolo que define el
papel de irlanda del norte que es parte
del reino unido y la república de
irlanda que es de la unión europea ha
sido el punto más difícil de implementar
del acuerdo al que se llegó para sellar
este break sheet en diciembre del año
pasado porque porque incluyó controles
fronterizos a los que los ciudadanos de
lado y lado pues no estaban
acostumbrados el gobierno británico dice
que hay que mejorar las reglas
comerciales
ahora tenemos que resolver la situación
que existe en irlanda del norte por eso
hemos presentado propuestas para cambiar
el protocolo para que las mercancías
puedan fluir más libremente de la emov
ls eso es perfectamente normal cambiar
los tratados a la luz de la experiencia
y sucede todo el tiempo por lo que hemos
propuesto una forma constructiva de
hacerlo y que dice a bruselas pues que
se opone a renegociar aunque si está
dispuesto a buscar otro tipo de solución
a este conflicto cambia nuevamente
información porque la actividad
económica en argentina creció en el mes
de mayo experimentó en el quinto mes un
crecimiento del 13,6 por ciento en
comparación con el mismo mes de 2007
pero pues esta es la tercera subida
interanual en más de 19 meses
consecutivos en bajada pero no hay que
hacerse muchas ilusiones porque aunque
parece un gran repunte en realidad no
desea que la comparación es muy baja
porque hace un año la economía pues
estaba paralizada además si la actividad
económica en mayo se compara con abril
presentó una caída del 2
por ciento lo que evidencia a raúl
cierto estancamiento en argentina así
española le pregunto por los indicadores
segundo día de ganancias en wall street
el miércoles después de que iniciara la
semana con nerviosismo por la
propagación de la variante delta las
bolsas de américa latina siguieron esta
misma tendencia en especial argentina
que subió casi 4% para finalizar le
pregunto qué nos trae como cifra el día
10 mil 100 millones de dólares estos
fueron los ingresos de cocacola en el
segundo trimestre que aumentaron 42 por
ciento frente al mismo período del año
pasado a medida de que sus clientes pues
van retomando lentamente sus hábitos de
consumo pre pandémico
danny y gracias entonces por toda la
información económica como siempre
ustedes también gracias si continúa con
nosotros aquí en france 24
[Música]